(Playful Music)
It's finally time to set up my Nintendo Switch!
Now that I have my 'Mood' lighting,
I actually made a Nintendo Switch lighting,
Like, I'm that freaking crazy.
Now you see it, now you don't. Right there.
Time to set this up.
(excessive music)
What're you telling me to do?
Alright, I'll do whatever you want.
Ooh it's telling me to do something~
We better do what it says.
So in my unboxing video, I called it
Nintendo Switch... Switcher, converter, something,
But apparently it's just called the Nintendo Switch Dock.
Set my icon, I'm definitely gonna be KK slider.
Yay it's me it's me!
I guess I should, insert my game card,
and there it is!
I'm just glad that this setup video didn't take very long,
Because now that means I get to actually go to play,
some Zelda, so...
I'll see you guys later. Just Kidding I'm not done yet.
You may have already seen the JoyCon controller
In my unboxing video, but here they are. Just in case
You haven't seen that.
They're pretty cool.
Very small, they definitely take a bit of getting used to.
So there's basically 3 ways to play Nintendo Switch,
Right now I'm playing on my big screen TV,
You can use the JoyCon controller just like this.
Free, one in each hand.
You can also connect to this controller,
And make yourself one big controller,
And then the third way,
Is the tablet way!
You just play here with the tablet,
Flip down this little kick stand,
And you can set it on your desk,
Can you see that? Even it's pretty far away,
I can still play using this controller,
I can also play with these separated,
I can also play, with these connected too!
So there's really so many different ways to
actually play this so, depending on your preferred
Gameplay style, that's probably what's best for you.
For me, I'm always on the go,
So I'm probably gonna play it like this,
Quite often. It does charge using USB-C,
So it'll be pretty easy to find yourself
An external battery charger, so if you're on the go,
Some reviews that I see, they say that you get a bunch of free hours if your
playing Zelda, breath of the Wild handheld style